this was Kate and Gerry McCann ten days
after their daughter Madeleine vanished
on the family holiday now those days
have turned into ten years and the
couple still have no idea what happened
to Madeline you don't realize how strong
you are until you have no option and I
think that's very true
obviously most events like this cause a
lot of reaction a lot of trauma and
upset but ultimately you have to keep
going and especially when you've got
other children involved I think before
Madeline was taken we felt we'd managed
to achieve a little perfect nuclear
family of five I had out for a short
period and I suppose you just this
almost the same way as if your child
becomes ill or Cetus let alone or has
died unlike many other families have
suffered and then your vision is altered
and you have to adapt and you adapt and
you have a new normality and
unfortunately for us new normality at
the minute as a family for Madeline was
nearly four years old when she vanished
from the family's holiday apartment in
Portugal to Portuguese police
investigations have found no proof of
her fate
nor has Scotland Yard which began its
own investigation six years ago
it told the McCanns this week it still
had one significant piece of evidence to
pursue I hope Madeline being out there
is no less than it was almost 10 years
ago I mean apart from those first 48
hours nothing actually has changed since
the enemy no I think the difficult thing
has always been how will we find her you
know she relied on the police doing
everything they can and you're relying
on somebody with information coming
forward I think that that's so important
that everyone thinks about how what
could have happened but some of the
scenarios with other people who have
been abducted and ket there's just so
unbelievable that you think that how
could that have happened
and that's probably what's going to
happen with Madeline's case it might not
be as quick as you want but there's real
progress being made so I think we need
to take heart from that and we just have
to go with the process and follow it
through whatever it takes for as long as
it takes you know but there's still hope
that we can find Madeline Madeline's
parents say there is still no evidence
that she's been harmed in the absence of
that they have real hope that their
daughter is alive and will one day be
reunited with them Martin brunt Sky News